as they race around the vertical track
they seem to be defying the law of
gravity centrifugal force keeps them
upright the faster they go the stronger
it gets Dave Seymour and his son Duke
push right to the physical limits as
they travel up to 80 km/h the force is
five times stronger than gravity anyone
traveling faster than this would risk
collapsing
we make it look too easy and it's not
easy if you're going too fast first
thing you feel is your blood going to
your legs and then if you go even faster
than that then you get white spots in
your eyes get tunnel vision and
everything zooms in on you yeah it's not
very good and then if you go too slow
you slip off the seam or family tours
Europe with the diamond Rome every year
this time they're at the goodwood
revival show a classic car festival in
southern England this type of stunt show
dates back to the late 19th century
first with bicycles then in the early
1920s with motorbikes performances such
as the wall of death became increasingly
spectacular around 100 different troops
were touring Europe by the 1930s there
was more walls so they were having to
put better shows on than their
competitors and so yes i'm more more
dangerous tricks more you know and then
they started putting lions on and
whether the line was drunk or something
to keep him up there other like i think
most of them didn't have any teeth the
diamond rome was built in 1927 and went
on sale in two thousand a first Dave
Seymour only wanted to buy us Indian
brand motorbikes they were typically
used for the wall of death but he got
the Drome for free over time he and his
son have come to feel quite at home on
the wall of death
natural I've been doing it since I was
14 so like I can stark and look at
people and smaller people it's one thing
being able to ride a bike but it's
another thing down ever smile and shout
and whoop and holler at the crowd and
and actually put a performance on
I think it was the only one with big
eyes wha I've never seen I can't believe
it then I haven't seen it I can't
believe it it's unbelievable it shows
brilliant I mean it just shows you what
side what you can do with determination
fantastic it's dangerous isn't it they
could die doing this scary stuff but
luckily no one was hurt but the show's
climax day puts his daughter on the
handlebars and bravely roars round with
the extra weight
I prefer doing it to watching it
actually it's scarier watching my family
get there that's lubing up there being
confident with myself it's worse for me
seeing my son Duke riding up there and
you just thinking can't come down there
that'll do that'll do you know it and of
course he's young he's he's he just
wants to do more and more spectators
throw-in money after riskier moves this
is the Accident Fund and they need it
insurance companies won't touch the
Seymours with a bargepole Dave and Duke
have a variety of broken bones behind
them the risk is it can it comes to bite
you when you're least expecting it so
you could have a puncher you know the
chain could come off but I wouldn't do
it if I feared it that much you know but
obviously you have to respect it you
have to respect it but yeah I enjoy it
and that's why I do and the see more
family doesn't plan on giving up anytime
soon they're constantly expanding their
repertoire they even had to reinforce
the wooden cylinder to accommodate their
homemade racecar
we've sort of fine-tuned it over the
years but there's still things we want
to do you know we're still involving it
you know vintages fashion at the moment
so I'm trying to keep the tradition
alive you know I'm just a custodian of
it i'm not you know I hope I don't look
at it as mine really it's just on I'm
keeping it for the next generation the
diamond Rome is almost 90 years old now
but Dave and Duke seymour are still out
there wow in crowds with their
gravity-defying stunts
you